when you look at this country you look
at a place like New York City you look
at a place like Los Angeles Chicago
these are the places that many
business-minded people many
entrepreneurs they have fled those
places and they're setting up camp in
places like Texas Florida Tennessee a
lot of the red states are there to
Americas where one is preserving the
American dream and preserving people's
ability to climb those ladders and one
that is crushing the American dream is
that a reality and now you have these
two very different Americas existing
within one country space yeah I mean
listen that's the beautiful thing about
the left wing and the right wing right
you need both of them to balance each
other out and anytime it goes too much
one side or the other then we're off
balance because now we're spinning if
you just keep being too much on the
right you're just going and you know
turns you're going too much on the left
you're going so we need to balance each
other out right and then the more we age
The More We Get Center the more we're
like yeah I'm conservative in these
areas this is kind of doesn't make sense
anymore I used to the other day we had
these two girls on the podcast just last
week and they were Google that through
tomato soup against the van Gogh
painting and then they grew themselves
and I said tell me why you're doing this
and then Katie Hopkins asked the
question of one of the girls and said
hey so Tommy uh who's paying for your
college tuition she's like uh my it's my
scholarship yeah but have you ever paid
a bill before never have you don't know
what life is all about you still got to
grow you still got to go through the
phases so in America if you got the
folks on the left who think they have
better ideas will improve it if your
ideas are better then people should be
coming to your city at a girl on the
other day Persian girl who called out uh
New York Times and on the podcast she
says you just need to know where I'm at
politically I'm for this I'm for BLM I'm
for LGBT I'm four pro-choice I'm four
everything she's like I'm four I'm four
and four no problem it's great that
you're for for all of that stuff where
you're politically you're favoring all
that stuff I said how do we judge a
great restaurant she says what do you
mean if the food is good I said no how
do we judge a gray restaurant so I don't
know I said I said have you ever been to
a restaurant where the restaurant is
fully empty during lunch time and that
was a great restaurant I said if you go
to a restaurant and it's empty during
dinner or lunch what does it tell you
man we better get out of here because
we're being fooled right but have you
ever been to a restaurant that's got a
45 minute wait where food is bad no and
she says uh maybe I said really because
now she knows where I'm going with this
all right I said really maybe I said
tell me who I said name me one
restaurant right that's full all the
time and tell me the food is bad tell me
your place
the only people that will call a
restaurant restaurant that's fully busy
and losing are the people that are
either competitors or former employees
those are the only people right so bring
that to politics I said certain channels
are always busy certain are empty
Florida's growing New York's losing you
know California is losing people for the
first time since 1851 Texas is picking
them up yeah so why is that happening
California is becoming an emptier
restaurant Texas and Florida is becoming
a fuller restaurant why are people
moving to Florida because better ideas
eventually win so a person can sit up
there and claim that their ideas are
better than somebody else at the end of
the day results are going to validate
your ideas are good or your ideas are
bad and right now ideas of New York
Illinois California are bad ideas so
what do you say to people I'm sure
you've heard this conversation about a
national divorce some people say the
differences are just too different
between what the right wants what the
left wants and I was somebody who always
shunned that idea I was always inclined
to say no it's good that the United
States is diverse let the best ideas win
let people move to places where those
ideas can flourish you know I'm a big
10th Amendment Advocate all of this
stuff however we're now at a point where
the hard left is so Bonkers in my view
that I don't want their toxicity
corrupting my place I don't want my
child exposed to that I don't want you
know the massive indoctrination when it
comes to gender ideology I don't want
all of a mandatory coveted vaccines for
kids I don't want for anyone for that
matter so there's a lot that's going on
where I look and I say I really
understand how we're essentially two
different Americas and maybe maybe it's
best to kind of be two different
Americas then can we really coexist in
one place and Will that toxic stuff
otherwise bleed into the rest of the
country and then take over is that a
possibility so do you understand the
mindset behind a national divorce a
peaceful National divorce I don't think
it's going to work because uh listen a
lot of people have breakups and then
they kiss up you know kiss you know kiss
and make up and hey I miss you you know
what do you miss about me I miss miss
you we're like this or miss you at first
a lot of times a woman or a guy will
break up with somebody and then a year
later two years later I'm like I screwed
up that was a good guy I was with I just
thought I wanted somebody like this now
you miss them so you know when it comes
down to uh uh let's just say if I was to
start a country to get you and I are
starting country together
and it's a brand spanking new country
people are thinking about choosing what
country to go to they don't have a lot
of options let's just say if a mother
wants to move to her kids to a country
what is the first thing a mother wants
first thing it's an S letter word safety
security right and we say she's going to
ask the question she's interviewing the
country so what does your country offer
uh you know we're going to give you
great benefits what do you mean we're
going to give you Social Security what
else are you going to give me we're
going to give you health insurance I
don't care about that stuff are my kids
safe am I safe so Define safe what is
safe are there cops
are there laws is there a military am I
protected are there borders yes then I'm
coming to your country that's the first
thing I'm going to ask the second thing
is going to be economy so tell me how
the economy is can I do anything I want
what are the regulations how big can I
build my business can I pursue my dreams
I'm a Hollywood person I'm creative I
want to do art can I create art go for
it I'm a business person I want to do
business go for it I'm a doctor we need
you I'm a dentist come on down I know
how to soak come on down I know how to
make shoes come I'm a painter we need
you I need I'm construction come on down
right but the first thing we're going to
ask is security the second thing we're
going to ask is opportunity upside right
okay so if a state doesn't value
protecting the safety of people's kids
protection with cops with military with
laws with if you don't do that a mother
is going to persuade the father to leave
to take their kids somewhere where
they're going to be safe my mom is the
reason we left Iran because she did not
feel safe for her kids to be there right
so as much as we do this divorce
eventually people are going to sit like
yesterday last week I had a guy in my
office
was part of the lgbtq community and he
was the agent of one of the guests that
I had I said so how you doing he says
good I said where are you from
originally from L.A where do you live
now I live in Florida I said wait you
live in Florida yeah politically what
side are you on oh I'm on the left why'd
you move to Florida I could no longer
deal with the the coveted restrictions
in California I said did you bring your
politics with you as well to Florida so
but because naturally we naturally want
security opportunity being left alone
and laws that don't give me security
don't give me opportunity and want to
force me to do something we run away
from that it doesn't matter what it is
if you want to watch the full episode
you're going to click right here and if
you want to ask me a question one on one
you want to do a one-on-one FaceTime
with a group of your friends whatever
you want you need to download manect
right now click right here and let's get
talking
foreign
[Music]